E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
é o que faz alguém querer fazer parte de
uma organização o que faz alguém se
apaixonar pelo lugar em que trabalha a
ponto de considerar a sua segunda casa
ou muitas vezes a sua primeira casa
trabalho sentidos felicidade Será que dá
para conciliar essas três coisas
e eu vou tentar responder aqui essas
perguntas trazendo uma reflexão com as
pontes que fizeram parte da minha vida e
que me Trouxeram aqui hoje essa é a
primeira delas
E essa foto me traz boas lembranças da
minha infância era ponte que ligava a
cidade onde eu morava no interior de
Santa Catarina a casa da minha avó a
Dona Geni lembra de mim pegar nos
estudos pois sabia que fazendo a minha
parte das férias poderíamos viajar para
casa da vó essa ponte conectava os meus
esforços a recompensa de ser recebida
por um abraço recheado de afeto e é com
esse afeto que eu sigo a minha caminhada
no mundo do trabalho ouvindo centenas de
colaboradores e empresas de diversos
estados sobre os motivos que os fazem
permanecer nas suas organizações
e foi quanto essa empresa me deu
oportunidade para crescer desenvolver na
minha função Foi quanto o meu gestor se
importou de verdade com a minha vida e
com a vida da minha família foi quando
eu vi o produto que eu faço sendo
reconhecido mundialmente estão as
histórias de amizade que essa empresa é
me trouxe e que ficaram para a vida
Olá pessoal percebo que as coisas que
mais fazem sentido nesses relatos não
são coisas são sentimentos são emoções e
são boas lembranças o que me mostrou que
o como se faz numa organização muitas
vezes tem mais valor para o colaborador
do que o que se faz o trabalho essa
ponte é ele que conecta a expectativa
que uma empresa tem a realidade que ela
deseja alcançar eu como boa publicitária
passei anos da minha vida convencendo as
pessoas a buscarem o outro lado da ponte
através de alguma solução que é
propaganda prometia
e por algum tempo isso faz sentido mas
não durou muito foi quando eu decidi
deixar a vida de propaganda de margarina
e entrar para a vida de pessoas reais
com desafios reais com problemas reais e
assim eu me vi trabalhando com aquilo
que sempre fez parte de mim a
comunicação do que é interno e foi onde
Eu me encontrei com em do marketing
curiosamente o prefixo lendo significa
dentro e a justamente o que eu considero
como o mais importante pois o que
realmente conecta as pessoas as suas
organizações é a verdade que está dentro
delas dentro das empresas e dentro das
pessoas e aí eu te pergunto Quais as
verdades que a sua empresa tem e cultiva
no caminho com seus colaboradores
e o que você posta nas redes sociais é o
que realmente você acredita ou melhor é
o que realmente você pratica e quer que
a sua empresa Atraia bons profissionais
que é que a sua marca seja reconhecida e
admirada por seus clientes Então pessoal
prática o que você fala acredito que
esse é o segredo para felicidade dentro
das organizações eu trabalhei por alguns
anos numa das maiores multinacionais
brasileiras em Jaraguá do Sul com em do
marketing e sou muito grata a história
que eu construir lá a trajetória que eu
vivi e aos amigos que fiz durante essa
jornada muitos está me assistindo agora
foi maravilhoso comunicado essas
milhares de colaboradores tudo que essa
empresa é tudo que ela faz de tudo que
ela acredita eu realmente me encontrei
nesse desafio de comunicar o que vem de
dentro
e esse encontro foi tão forte que eu
queria compartilhar essa minha paixão
com outras pessoas e organizações de
todo o Brasil foi quando decidi ter meu
próprio negócio acreditei que poderia
ajudar outras empresas a se relacionarem
de uma maneira mais interessante com
seus colaboradores através da
comunicação E sabe o que aconteceu
tudo se mostrou tão certo então efetivo
quando o meu coração dizia que seria até
que um dia em fevereiro de 2011 me
deparei com a Segunda Ponte da minha
história que impactou de uma forma
Inesperada a minha vida tanto como
profissional quanto pessoa não sei o quê
Qual a sensação que você tem eu ver essa
imagem
para mim o primeiro momento ela está a
sensação de perda de desespero de
atropelos sonhos aos projetos EA vida
que eu tinha planejado
bom e foi isso mesmo que aconteceu eu
estava caminhando com meu próprio
negócio já tinha uma mesa de escritório
um telefone e um computador e eu tinha
até um cliente eu tinha tudo e de
repente no fim de tarde eu simplesmente
não tinha mais nada minha casa onde eu
morava e trabalhava foi atingida por uma
enchente o que restou dela foi uma mesa
de madeira maciça que resistiu a água
dizendo a mim que podemos ser firmes
frente aos desafios mais intensos e
também bolinhas coloridas todas
espalhadas pelo lodo me lembrando que
aquele cantinho onde a minha filha
Helena se divertir enquanto eu
trabalhava era a prova de que se pode
ainda juntar os cacos e seguir em frente
com otimismo e com alegria
e é nessas situações que a gente viu
quanto que um caminho Próspero não é
feito só de ganhos e as perdas também
fazem parte dele precisamos olhar para
ela ficou empatia e gratidão para poder
ressignifica-las essa ponte é uma
metáfora que traduz muito bem o que
estamos vivendo nesse momento a pandemia
chegou com uma uma enchente e acabou
atingindo milhares de empresas que
tinham Pontes aparentemente firmes
sólidas que acreditavam que a forma que
se relacionavam com seus públicos era
realmente efetiva quantas paredes foram
substituídas por telas quanto os
sistemas de comando e controle ficaram
sem sentido precisando ser substituídos
por maneiras de melhorar a autonomia EA
confiança no na entrega
tô numa crise numa enchente ou numa
pandemia pessoal o que realmente importa
na sua organização
Porque que as pessoas continuarem
acreditando na sua marca
e quem está com você nesse caminho o que
está do outro lado da ponte e o que
todos devem fazer para chegar lá as
respostas para estas perguntas são as
mensagens da sua comunicação é a sua
verdade e o que você deve como líder e
como pessoa valorizar compartilhar e
celebrar com aqueles que estão ao seu
lado
e nesse momento olhar para dentro é
fundamental
passamos muito tempo da nossa vida
olhando para fora para ser feliz a
história do outro para a empresa do
outro para a vida do outro nas redes
sociais e de tanto olhar para fora
acabamos fechando os olhos para o
interno para o dentro de nós e de nossas
empresas Eu sei que não é fácil é para
dentro e às vezes até dói mas esse olhar
é a base de todo o processo de mudança e
crescimento
a praça operado dia da enchente da minha
vida aí eu olhei à minha volta e percebi
que várias coisas que a água levou
realmente não eram tão necessárias assim
olha aí também para dentro de mim e
percebi teu principal que eu precisava
para seguir em frente a minha família os
meus amigos e o meu propósito de
aproximar empresas e colaboradores
através das verdades de cada um Eu
lembro que na manhã seguinte era uma
segunda-feira entre todo lodo e o caos
que se encontrava a minha empresa é a
minha vida a minha cliente me liga
pedindo se eu conseguiria entrar
Entregar até o final do dia o que
havíamos combinado na sexta
e eu respirei fundo e disse sim
mesmo não deixando que ela soubesse que
entre a sexta EA segunda feira uma
enchente havia arrastado a minha casa a
minha empresa e também a mim
e eu juro que eu não sei como eu fiz mas
eu fiz e essa força tremenda que parte
de dentro da gente e tem impacto no
mundo que eu chamo de sentido Essa é a
ponte que nos conecta algo que nos faz
sentir a felicidade
Essa é a terceira ponte e sim um sorriso
O sorriso nada mais é do que uma ponte
que liga a alma ao corpo é a expressão
da Felicidade em saber que o trabalho
pode proporcionar o sentido maior que
transforma a vida das pessoas por onde
ela Impacta
e o professor e psicólogo Martins L mann
fala no seu livro A Felicidade autêntica
que a felicidade é determinada de
sessenta por cento por fatores genéticos
e circunstâncias da nossa vida e que os
quarenta por cento são determinados por
nossos comportamentos e ações ou seja
pessoal ninguém nenhuma organização é
totalmente responsável pela felicidade
dos seus colaboradores mas ela pode sim
contribuir com ações e situações que
promovam um ambiente seguro saudável e
que gere emoções positivas nas pessoas
como ter relações mais felizes entre
pessoas e empresas e colaboradores no
presente no futuro
olhe para dentro da sua empresa e
Reforce com seus colaboradores as
verdades que existem nesta relação
Valorize as Três Pontes que comentamos
aqui hoje a primeira é a sua história é
de onde você veio e o que te trouxe até
aqui a segunda é a sua razão o seu
sentido o que faz seguir em frente e a
terceira seu caminho e tudo o que está
nele que vale a pena se orgulhar os seus
produtos os seus desafios os seus
processos a sua cultura suas conquistas
as suas pessoas que já qual for a ponte
que conecta a sua empresa ao seu
colaborador olhe para ela e Valorize
esse caminho
eu percebi assim o destino mas não
esqueça de sorrir durante a jornada
Equidade quem caminha com você
E qual é o sentido do seu trabalho o meu
é continuar construindo Pontes muito
obrigada a
[Aplausos]
[Música]